am Dienstag werden im
Verteidigungsministerium in Wien die
erfolgreichsten sommersportlerinnen und
Sommersportler des Bundesheeres von
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
einmal mehr ausgezeichnet bei insgesamt
82 gewonnenen Medaillen lohnt ein Blick
auf die abgelaufene Saison wir kommen
jetzt gerade aus Doha zurück vom
weltcupfale wo die 15 besten der Welt
eingeladen sein und wir seind seit
langer langer Zeit war mit drei Athleten
wieder dabei gewesen und das SG schon
wie stark dass wir als gesamtes Team auf
en nächstes Jahr werden die Olympischen
Spiele in Paris ausgetragen und da sind
noch nicht alle Qualifikationen positiv
erledigt ich jetzt no
Qualifikationsphase vor mir das Heß es
gibt zwei Europameisterschaften wo es
Quotenplätze gibt und ein Quotenplatz
über Qualifikationsturnier und
ne über die wöung Listen und das fährt
dann am 96 ist sozusagen Stichtag und
dann wissen wir was Sache ist über einen
sogenannten Quotenplatz bereits fix bei
Olympia dabei ist Sportschütze Alexander
schmir also für Paris erwte eigentlich
dass ich so meine Leistungen von der
Saison wieder abrufen kan hab voragende
Saison gehabt mit wmastertitel und hoffe
dass ich da in Paris an die Leistungen
anknüpfen kann und dann hwegs wieder
sehr vorne mitspielen sehr vorne
mitspielen würde mit Sicherheit auch
Österreichs karateas Betina Planck zu
ihrem leitwesen ist ihr Sport allerdings
leider nicht mehr olympisch im Namen der
Olympischen Spiele der Ringe viermal
Starter dürfer der Weise dürfer und
viermal Medaille homk künner und es
waren immer unglaublich tolle Erlebnisse
für Verteidigungsministerin Claudia
Tanner ist die hohe Zahl der sportlichen
Erfolge besonders beeindruckend es ist
ein unfassbares Bild ja man wirklich
Atem berauben 82 Medaillen dieungen
werden Konten in der abgelaufenen Saison
ich glaub das Erfolgsgeheimnis ist dass
unsere Sportlerinnen und Sportler Sie
einfach auf den Sport konzentrieren
können und sich nicht damit beschäftigen
müssen wo krieg das Gott her um keine
sozialrechtliche Absicherung auch
müssen und ich meine die soldatischen
Eigenschaften passen schon sehr gut mit
denen zusammen auch die Sportler braucht
ja wenn man Disziplin den
Leistungswillen auch denkt und dann das
nie aufgeben oder nach Niederlagen
einfach wieder
[Musik]
aufzustellen